marcus strowman starts from behind the
mound just in case they change the rules
they might do that at some point gary
well they've already started in uh one
of the independent leagues they're going
from 61 feet six inches if you start at
70 feet 61 it's gonna be nothing
well for straw i think it's a good setup
for him to tell you the truth against
this young
ball club of course we've talked a lot
about how many players they've traded
gives them a chance maybe to get some
early out early outs early in the count
victor robles will lead off 91 degrees
at game time at citi field two seven
inning games today and um i'll say my
piece with my fingers crossed yes
there's no rain in the forecast oh oh
two coming from strowman and he's struck
him out with the slider and strowman has
a strikeout of robles to start the
afternoon
and he got him looking
at the knees on the outside corner bell
is out stromer with a couple of
strikeouts in the first inning that's
come to bat no score
drafted by the toronto blue jays
involved in the
josh donaldson trade early in his career
he has been everywhere in his career
31 years old
first outing in the big league since
2015 when he made six starts for the a's
a lot of injuries and a lot of travel
since then this time
turn and he skids one over the bag and
dom's got a base hit how about that
nolan throwing every trick in the book
at the mets that time the louis teont
back to home play turn
and don was able to fight it off and get
himself a hit here's jd davis a couple
of doubles in yesterday's game and he
hits one sharply and into left field for
a base hit
dom takes a turn he's going to try for
third and hernandez will let him go
good
base running by dom with his head off
oh like some cutting action to the
outside edge are there a bouts and the
foul tip two k's for sean nolan welcome
back to the big leagues sir
off the end of the bad it appeared kibum
puts a pretty good carry on it that ball
is going to
drop out in the gap
he's going to make the round of first
and return
carter boom muscles one out into left
center
there goes garcia throwing from his
knees neato a perfect throw and he got
him oh wow
thomas nedo from his knees a laser beam
to get garcia and end the inning
that was something
mcneil with the tag side retired
the 2-2 lined up the middle base hit
going into center field
in the yard turns first and holds on and
he's got the met's third hit of the game
a lead off single here in the second as
storm tries to butt his way on a
beautiful bunt and they'll never throw
him out
gorgeous by strowman for his fourth end
of the year
could not have bunched it any better
so now two out and two on for nimmo
three two to nimo with the runners going
he drills one deep to right field toward
the wall
drive three-run homer
number three for nemo and it's
three-nothing new york
line to center again back in florida
this one falls for a base hit
so two liners in the same direction and
this one fell in front of robles and
conforto was aboard punch the other way
and that'll sneak through for a basic
and four or around second he'll go on to
third
nito got very little of that ball
right off the end of the bat probably
broke it but he snuck it through the
infield and the mets have runners at
first and third runner goes from first
and neato steal second
they ignore tomas nedo and he steals
second base
it's just a bad defensive play by the
first baseman you can't leave
too early because we talked about kibum
leaving his position bell leaves his
position early allows nido to take the
extra step first career stolen base for
tomas nito
so one out and now nimo coming up
2-2 coming and nimo slashes one over the
bag that's a fair ball in the score is
conforto nieto stops at third fourth rbi
of the game for nemo he has driven in
all the runs in the midst lead for
nothing inside and alonzo is drilled
[Applause]
he appears okay
takes a little stare out of machado and
machado spreading his arms as if to say
i didn't mean that and now alonso
looking back at him and making a little
motion i think alonso was saying what
are you looking at
i think that was the gist of that
conversation machado said not much i
guess both managers stepped out of their
dugout and rojas is going to go over to
make sure that alonso is okay
most of the players stay put
just a little jawing back and forth
alonzo not enjoying getting hit and
machado
[Applause]
and he
had some words well that's the issue i
always hear from folks say well why do
they get angry you know he didn't mean
to hit you you ever been hit with a
baseball you get angry straight away it
looks like you got him on the right
thumb which is not a good place to get
hit
i mean
he never is able to close up
i mean he was completely open to that
ball as he's starting to take his swing
and never
that ball deflected and hit him in the
right collarbone could hit him in the
face
on the deflection
yeah i think it's the thumb they're more
concerned about though
yeah i can read lifts but i can't on the
air
pitch up means fastball
he didn't get it all the way up there
but he got to stryker
machado good job of limiting the damage
nimmo got the ground ball base hit
alonzo hit and then two case and it
stays mets by four
stevenson jammed and gets it through
stopping at second adams
and the nats have doubled their hit
total
with that swing
robles hits one hard that's by
davison to the left field corner hits
and comes out in front of dominic smith
so scoring is
adams third base stevenson
and victor robles who's now six for his
last 15
gets the nats on the board
one-two coming struck him out
there's the change-up from strowman the
fan escobar and get the first out of the
inning and that's gonna be the last man
he faces one two coming to bell
up the middle right there is mcneil the
flip to vr and the high throw
[Applause]
[Applause]
alonzo going high and getting the tag on
bell
nicely done by pete with the ballet move
and the nats are down to their final out
in game one and he flies one into
shallow right center should be easy for
conforto as he battles the sun nemo
comes over to help makes the catch in
the ball game is over
back-to-back saves for edwin diaz in the
first two games of the series the mets
have won two straight for the first time
in three weeks
it's marcus strowman throws five and a
third terrific innings and brandon nimmo
does all the damage with the bat as the
mets beat the nationals 4-1